[Music]  is this Clark this interstellar coming  don't see Clark oh maybe he's still  sleeping dad are now expected to enter  our atmosphere that's why they say more  understand what are you going I don't  know when first chance is about to hit  it's only part of it it's going the  ocean but you what is the explosion  we now are getting word that the  fragment has gets Central Florida  wait are some more pieces going here  come on let's go  two days they got it all wrong there's a  ton of fragment mana killer space  agencies are predicting an extinction  level event we're gonna be together  alright could you just try to get to  safety they've been tracking the  military flights to bunkers and  Greenland it's our only chance  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  get my family if you are hearing this  broadcast seek shelter immediately what  is it what's wrong  [Music]